hey what's up guys my name is deterno
welcome back to another hazel devlog
and happy new year it's uh 13th of
january it's
like halfway through the month i finally
dragged myself out of bed
finally here making another video for
you guys it's been it's been rough
coming back from holidays is always like
the worst but i do have some extremely
exciting news today this is going to be
one
entertaining devlog hopefully because
the features are just
they're just flying into hazel but this
time
it's not just me that you have to thank
so over the last year really the
community for hazel has really
grown quite a lot and there are a lot of
people interested in contributing to
hazeldev
which is amazing now whilst we're not
quite hiring full-time engineers who
work on hazel
just yet some people have been extremely
generous with their help on hazeldev and
has gotten to the point where i've
informed a little bit of like a hazel
core team
and we work on on hazel peter 1745
is the person to thank today i want to
give a huge shout out to peter
1745 this is his username on discord i
don't even know what his
full name is he is the person who has
made possible what we're about to look
at today which is
3d physics and hazel that's right
starting the year off with
3d physics pretty cool so hazel dev has
had 2d physics for a while using box 2d
something i added a few months ago
but obviously it was it's it's desirable
to have 3d physics and a 3d game engine
because whilst 2d physics is nice and
you know you can still run yourself in
3d but have 2d physics
overall you probably want to have some
kind of 3d physics solution now this is
something that
i was kind of putting off for a while
because it wasn't
strictly necessary i wanted to get kind
of the fundamentals done and like 2d
physics but then peter showed up and was
like hey man
i i want to slap phys x and video physx
into hazel so
can i do that and i was like absolutely
so here we are today
now one thing i want to point out is
that um again me and peter have worked
have worked quite a bit on this features
there's been a lot of back and forth
it's been really like
like having a development team which i'm
really grateful for because as a solo
developer it's really nice when i get to
speak to people but overall peter as if
he needs
more like cool points the reason why
peter stands out to me is because i've
i've had a lot of people from the
community common and
understandably you know contribute code
that that isn't like
that great or like you know it's fine
for like an open source community
because you know when you have the
community contributing code
this standard of code is typically lower
than you would find in like a
professional team
understandably because experienced
engineers are probably spending their
time
you know doing paid work but every now
and then someone comes along and writes
code
and and and works on a feature at a
professional level to the point where
like
if the person was actually employed by
me as like a full-time engineer in hazel
i would be satisfied with their work and
i think peter is
is one of one of one of those people the
game engine series of hazel
has always been something that like is
more of an educational series i'm more
okay with
people kind of taking that and doing
doing stuff to it that i
maybe wouldn't necessarily agree with i
still see myself as like the
kind of technical director of that
project but
it's more of like a community
involvement thing whereas hazeldev is
kind of like
my baby hazeldev is like my engine that
i'm secretly making behind the scenes to
to both know what to teach in the game
engine series but then also to
eventually
you know develop my own games in and to
serve as like an educational resource
to people who want to go a little bit
past the game engine series and
get into the more serious stuff so
because of that i'm way more picky
with the kind of code that i end up
accepting because
in a lot of cases it just makes more
sense for me to write the code because
it's
like my engine if that makes sense so
anyway long story short peter has done
some absolutely amazing work
and we now have physx inside hazel now
there are a lot a lot more things that
i'm still working on like integrating
with c-sharp scripting a little bit
better and adding more features in
general like you know nvidia physics is
a huge library there's a lot of really
nice examples out there it's very
straightforward easy to use
3d physics library i think it's very
powerful it's definitely the solution i
would pick over something like bullet
it's a really nice 3d physics library
and it's definitely my top choice for
hazel
so what can we now do well i mean what
can't we do
i feel like with 3d physics inside hazel
now you know
we've got 2d physics we've got 3d
physics we've got like you know a full
editor where you can like move things
around and enter play mode we've got
c-sharp scripting like you could
definitely
put together some game in inside hazel
and
uh yeah we're going to do that i'm not
going to talk too much about that in
this video because of course i want to
reserve this video for
3d physics but in the future very soon
probably i'll be putting out a video
talking about what my goals are for this
year and making something is definitely
one of my primary goals for this year
because i think that hazel is definitely
getting to the point where we can
actually
start driving hazel's features by having
an actual project
rather than still kind of messing around
with the sandbox which is a really
exciting stage to be in
in the life of a game engine anyway
without further ado i know you guys want
to see the physics i want to show you
like building a scene from the ground up
adding some physics subjects kind of the
whole workflow i've been refining the
work for a little bit making sure
everything works
over the last couple days and uh yeah
it's very exciting stuff
now whilst it's it's kind of mostly i
would say mostly working there's still a
wide variety of like edge cases and like
other optimization issues and stuff that
we have to sort out so
for now it's in a separate branch called
physx inside the hazel dev repository
for those of you who have access to that
who are patrons you can uh you can clone
the branch and
take a look at it for yourself one of
the coolest things about hazel dev i
think is the rapid development of
features i mean sure the features aren't
like fully qa tested and production
ready
but i i think the pace at which we're
able to kind of produce these features
is really really cool and i think that
the best feedback i receive from a lot
of people who do have access to this
stuff is just
how as soon as they're done playing with
one feature something else just comes up
so
that kind of stuff makes me really happy
and that's something that i appreciate
working on a small scale project like
hazel
rather than something else like some
large game engine in the industry
anyway let's finally take a look at the
physics
okay so i've got this fairly empty scene
here all i've done is added a camera
directional light and a skylight just so
that we can actually see something
so if i play the scene obviously we just
have an empty scene let's go ahead and
set up some 3d physics
so if you right click and go to create
i've added some more options here to be
able to just quickly make things so that
you don't have to add empty entities and
then
start adding a whole bunch of components
so we have some meshes here but then we
also have physics
i'll walk you through the the kind of
basic way to add physics stuff without
just using the presets though so if we
just
spawn in like a little cube here's our
little cube
looks great let's scale it up a little
bit so we can see it and then maybe
let's uh duplicate the cube drag it down
a bit and i'm going to make like a
little floor plane out of it
so i'll just maybe shrink it down that
looks pretty good i think
maybe let's move this cube up a bit make
it smaller okay so now what i want to do
is actually
simulate some physics so if i hit the
play button
we of course just see the geometry as
you would expect
nothing too fancy let's see if we can
make this cube fall
and will crash onto the ground so if i
click on the cube and i go add component
i can add a rigid body
now i'll set this to be dynamic because
we want it to actually move
not just for other bodies to collide
with it there's a whole bunch of
settings here and constraints and stuff
like that that
you can play around with as well and
then i'll add a box collider
so this box collider which shows up in
green like this
represents the actual physx collider
so this is this is the part that's
actually going to collide with things
now you can resize it as you can see i
can play around with these settings
and it's possible to make something that
doesn't align with the geometry
but by default because this is a one
meter cubed kind of cube so one by one
by one meter
and this is one by one by one they match
up right and if you scale it up
obviously or you play with the scale
that's also going to match
as well so let's set this back to uh
well we don't have to have it like
as a perfectly uniform cube but we've
basically created
an object with a box collider um also
the shadows seem to disappear when i
select things i forgot to fix that
before the video that's awkward but
anyway we'll keep going
so if i select this and it only it only
seems to happen when we select uh
things with actual um you know collision
geometry which is weird
but anyway so if i select this um and i
well first of all let's just hit play
right
so now it falls brilliant but let's make
it collide with this so we'll go ahead
and go to add components and then we'll
add a rigid body we'll make it static
though
and then we'll also add a box collider
so really all we need for these things
are box cloud is we don't have to like
deal with
meshes and mesh colliders we'll explore
that a little bit later today
but for now this is really all we need
if i hit play now our cube
is here right and it collides amazing
let's uh drag this up
this is pretty cool i'm not gonna lie i
would be i would act more amazed but i
have been like
working with this kind of stuff for like
the last few weeks
so to be honest i'm almost a little bit
sick of it but anyway let's uh
run this little simulation here looks
pretty good there we go
let's go ahead and add a new uh mesh
or a new physics sphere so now we have
the same thing but this is like an
actual sphere let's drag it up
scale it up maybe what i'll do is i'll
actually come over here to the materials
panel and i'll add something i'll add
some albedo
to this so if we go assets i don't know
i'll just go to like
meshes maybe we'll use the cerberus
texture
um also i'll check that as used and
maybe i'll make it like
plastic just so that we can actually see
it roll um
and so if i hit play here then the uh
whoops we forgot to add a
to make this dynamic and if we hit play
here there we go
so that was a bit uh not as fun as i
thought it would be
uh maybe let's try again
it's just landing on that cube perfectly
let's try a different angle
yeah okay
we can always add more spheres
and have them collide with each other
okay and then you can see the sphere is
rolling
okay so that is some basic 3d
physics
this of course is pretty cool but it can
get a whole lot cooler
if you actually have like some kind of
world or some terrain that you want to
collide with
so let's quickly go into blender and i'm
just going to make a brand
new mesh here we'll make a new cube
maybe i'll uh scale this up kind of like
this and what i want to do with this is
actually just make like
some terrain honestly now let's make
sure the scale isn't negative because
that would be annoying
uh let's drag this maybe down a little
bit i'm gonna go into edit mode this
isn't really a blender tutorial but what
i'm gonna do is just basically
tessellate this a lot i'm gonna make a
whole bunch
more vertices uh pretty much everywhere
um
on this kind of surface so that should
be that should be okay
and i'm just going to manipulate some of
them by using like a
little soft selection here which
sometimes
doesn't the shortcut doesn't work for
some reason
okay and now we're able to just kind of
create some nice terrain right so i'll
just uh maybe
drag this up
make some kind of hills here maybe i
will make
like in the middle i'll make like a
little
recessed kind of dip here and then
maybe i'll even make some kind
of uh
river here or something it's almost like
a little dip
uh like a little platform that's just
recessed there okay that should be
enough let's make sure we
shade this smooth uh and then
if i really wanted to i'd probably go to
the modifiers and add like a subdivision
surface
modifier maybe let's just do one
we'll see what that looks like and then
if we apply that
i'm just kind of concerned okay that's
not too bad so we have about about
like 3866 vertices according to that so
that should be okay because obviously
with physics meshes you don't want to
make them too detailed otherwise your
performance will suffer
that looks pretty good i almost liked it
better without the subdivision but we'll
keep that just to demonstrate
a high quality mesh okay so i'll go file
export
fbx and then if we go ahead and go to
our little physics demo folder that i
prepared earlier
let's go ahead and physics mesh this
i'll set the scale to 0.01 just so that
we convert to meters and i'll export the
fbx
okay so now let's let's kind of delete
this thing
and instead what we'll do is we'll add
an empty mesh and then we'll go ahead
and load that
so if i go over here to our folder i'll
load the fbx file
here it is as you can see it looks
completely wrong let's go back
probably would have been a good idea to
actually apply the transformation before
i started messing with all the vertices
but maybe we can save it if i go
to wireframe and just recalculate the
normals
and there we go let's let's try and
re-export that
there we go real live for devlog and you
can see me mess up
let's go ahead and i already deleted it
and add that empty mesh back in
okay looks pretty good to me so um let's
go ahead and uh
maybe not make it um like a shiny
plastic let's make it
more rough and maybe i'll even make it
a kind of green color just like that so
that it's more of like a terrain color
uh and then i can just go to add
component and then
uh well we'll add our rigid body but
then we'll add a mesh collider instead
of
instead of a box collider so if i add a
mesh collider
this will actually generate a mesh
collider with physx and you can see that
it looks pretty good so now technically
speaking if i was to like drag this yarn
to this
on to this mountain it should just roll
off the mountain when i hit play
and there you go right so we have an
actual mesh collider
let's go ahead and scale this up maybe a
little bit and we can move this around
so that our world gets larger i'm not
sure if that'll be
fully captured by the camera so maybe
let's move the
camera back a bit more maybe i'll set
the field of view a little bit wider
okay and there you can see our little
physics simulation looking pretty good
so let's make that roll off that
mountain that looks good i think
okay so that is an example of these mesh
clients being used now it's not very
difficult
to then take this and obviously add like
a little capsule collider
and an actual fps camera so that we can
actually move around this terrain and
jump around and we'll collide with
everything
so that's probably something that i will
in fact save for the next
devlog but i think this should give you
a pretty decent idea
of the kind of stuff that is now
possible okay so as i mentioned
loads of stuff that we can still show
here but that's going to be it for this
video hope you guys enjoyed please let
me know what you thought of this and
what you thought of the workflow and
just your general thoughts in the
comment section below don't forget that
you can help support the development of
this
as well as get access to everything that
you've seen here today by going to
patreon.com
huge thank you to everyone who does help
support the series we wouldn't be here
without you hazel would not be
at the stage that it is at if it wasn't
for you guys and your support i think
that where we've come
so far even though to me this still
still seems like
the absolute beginning of a game engine
it's really
quite incredible and i think that we as
a community have something to be proud
of because i don't think
a lot of people can can say that they've
managed to build something like this and
we have so i'm really really proud of
this community and of all of you guys
for all of your contributions and for
even watching my videos and supporting
and everything like that
you know um i think i had a lot of time
to reflect over the holidays of this
kind of
few weeks that i had off from making
youtube videos and i really am so
grateful
for the community and to be in the
position that i am i am in and i'm
so so excited for the future because
this is this is like
honestly the absolute beginning my new
year's resolution for this year is to
work harder and
hopefully i'm going to be able to prove
that with hazel and with this channel
and with everything that i do so
strap yourselves in it's going to be a
wild ride i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you